Secura got you dying a whole bunch are
you feeling utterly demoralized
well don't worry we've got some tips to
help you become the best shinobi you can
be
[Music]
the dilapidated temple serves as
Sakura's main hub area in which you can
craft new prosthetics upgrade your
healing gourd or just relax throughout
your journey you'll pick up several key
items that unlock new mechanics and
tools however you won't be able to
utilize them unless you go back to the
temple so make it a priority to halt
progress in return as soon as possible
Seck euros combat is all about breaking
an enemy's posture which is the gauge
below their health bar you're trying to
max it out in order to dismantle their
defense and inflict a death blow while
sword attacks help with the general
effort it's ultimately your ability to
deflect their attacks that does the most
damage to posture a deflection is
performed by timing a guard right at the
moment an enemy's attack makes contact
as you can imagine this takes a bit of
practice to master luckily there's a
fella named Hana be an undead samurai
who hangs out at the dilapidated temple
who you can practice deflection against
without having to worry about dying this
is a nice way to practice the game's
combat mechanics as well as get a feel
for any new attacks or techniques you
unlock from the many skill trees however
the best way to train is to find an area
near a sculptors Idol filled with
varying enemy types and just work from
there Hanabi is a decent foe to test
your deflection skills against but it's
in practical situations where you can
gather the most valuable knowledge in
insight about your strengths and
weaknesses in not only deflection but in
in general fight in addition practicing
deflection against varying groups of
enemies and larger more intimidating
foes is essential as you're often thrown
into dire situations with them during
the game's more challenging areas
[Music]
an incredibly important enemy thing to
watch out for in a fight are what the
game calls perilous attacks which are
devastating maneuvers sign posted by a
read kanji symbol
there are three types that you'll
encounter thrust sweep and grab thrust
can be deflected but the timing required
to do so is incredibly precise you're
able to acquire a skill in the shinobi
arts tree called mercury counter that
enables you to stop down on a thrusting
enemy's weapon dealing great damage to
their posture however sweep and grab
cannot be deflected and must be jumped
over or stepped dodged away from
respectively to achieve the most optimal
results recognizing the perilous attack
type and enemy is about to perform is
essential to survival if you're ever
unsure what's coming your way try
hanging back to better study the enemy's
perilous attack repertoire and speed
incorporate this into your practice of
timing deflections and you'll learn to
quickly deal with any challenge in enemy
throws at you
[Music]
in your attempts to perfectly deflect
and counter enemy attacks your posture
is likely going to break numerous times
if you're a Souls player your main
instinct is probably to let your guard
down to recover however doing so
actually decreases your postures
recovery time if your posture is high
instead remain in guard stance to
replenish it faster
in addition healing yourself makes your
posture clearer quicker so the higher
your health the quicker the recovery
the rules of posture apply to enemies as
well and becomes crucial to pay
attention to during boss fights enemies
can be killed more traditionally by
emptying their health bar but it's far
more efficient to max their posture
meter and deal a death blow if you want
to keep that meter filled up you have to
keep dealing damage and deflecting
attacks backing off to get a breather or
healing up is useful but if you wait too
long their posture will replenish and
all that work will be wasted if you ever
run into an enemy that's simply
replenishing posture far too quickly try
damaging their health first you'll
notice that their posture begins to
change color from a light orange to a
deep red the darker the color the easier
it is to deal posture damage and the
longer it takes for them to replenish as
the one-armed wolf you're equipped with
an arsenal of useful tools you can
attach to your shinobi prosthetic arm
your head may get wrapped up in trying
to deflect encountering attacks but do
not forget about these some have pretty
obvious functionality such as the loaded
axe which can break enemy's shields
however the usefulness of others like
the loaded shuriken and the flame vent
may fade into obscurity for you every
tool has a very specific use during
combat so make sure to read each one's
description to get attuned to its
purpose
for example the flame vent can scare
this troublesome ogre fella giving you
ample opportunity to attack be adaptive
and resourceful with your shinobi
prosthetics tools as they can literally
save your life in most combat situations
this is an obvious tip but nonetheless
an important one especially for all you
souls born players out there yes you can
pause the game in Sec euro so there's no
more of that panicked item equipping and
unequipping from previous from sophomore
games use this to your advantage when
squaring up against enemies or bosses
who exhibit characteristics that call
for the use of other special tools or
items in your inventory that or to take
a break because let's be real you're
gonna need it with how brutally tense
this game's combat encounters get
compared to other from software games
one of Sakura's most standout features
is the ability to jump
this adds verticality to encounters
allowing you to jump to either dodge
attacks or leapfrog off foes the latter
is performed by jumping towards an enemy
and pressing jump again as you get close
to kick off them it's a great way the
deal posture damage jumping is a big
part to the general flow of combat so
make sure you're taking advantage of it
another unique quality is the fact that
you have unlimited stamina sprint dodge
jump and attack to your heart's content
while paying particular mind to link
these actions together in acrobatic and
strategic ways though be mindful of when
to show restraint after all this is
still a from software game so Swift
punishment still comes to those who move
and attack carelessly
[Music]
when direct confrontation isn't the most
viable option you're able to sneak past
enemies and murder them from behind
above or while hanging from a Ledge look
to nearby rooftops and bushes to take
cover and plan your attack always take
note of the kinds of enemies in the area
and prioritize your stealth kills
accordingly for example if you encounter
a rifleman and a spearmen standing next
to one another you'll want to take down
the ladder as you can easily take down
the other with only a few slashes you
can also use a stealthy backstab to
knock a free health bar off powerful
mini bosses that is if you're able to
get the jump on them don't hesitate to
use stealth often especially if you're
not confident enough to take on more
fearsome foes as you can easily inflict
an instant killing blow on them when
they're not looking
however be mindful that it doesn't work
on every single enemy
regardless stealth is always a great
strategy whether you're using it to
sneak past enemies ambush them or break
line of sight
[Applause]
being a proper shinobi isn't just about
performing perfect deflections and being
super sneaky it's also about being
well-informed about your surroundings as
you sneak about you'll notice that
there's often an option to eavesdrop on
guards while some of these conversations
are mostly intended as flavored dialogue
they can offer you intel on the
locations of valuable tools or incoming
threats I'll come in with Hugh this
isn't the only way to gain Intel though
you can get information from special
merchants just as long as you've got the
coin to cover their asking fees
[Music]
despite your best efforts you're likely
to get stuck on a boss early on instead
of spending hours beating your head
against a wall trying to overcome the
challenge know that there's typically
another area you can travel to SEC euros
world is rather open in this regard
often allowing you to make progress
elsewhere if you find yourself
ill-prepared to take on what lies ahead
in the area you're currently in buying
coin purses with your money might not
make much sense at first but they're
well worth getting to ensure that you've
got extra coin to spend in emergencies
after all dying costs a chunk of your
money which can go pretty quickly when
you're up against a tough boss
[Music]
always be on the lookout for NPCs while
they typically share important
information
a few also have special side quests
attached to them completing these tasks
earns you some pretty substantial
rewards such as upgrade materials and
access to a completely new skill tree
[Music]
you know what's absolutely mind-blowing
about Secura you could swim that's right
you can actually wade through water to
explore out of reach locations this
stands in stark contrast to other from
software games where water meant death
anyway there are some useful items to be
found by swimming about one of the most
important items you can find our
treasure carp scales which you can get
by killing the occasional carp as
seemingly inconsequential collectible
these scales are used as a currency for
a special potted merchant you can find
at the Hirata estate you'll see this
little fella tucked away at the
rightmost side of the lake early in the
area he's literally a pot with a hand
sticking out of it you can't miss him
you can purchase some useful items from
him such as the withered red gourd a
refillable potion that increases your
burn resistance definitely seek him out
anyway we hope you found all these tips
useful there were there any others that
you had that you think would help folks
out let us know in the comments below
thanks for watching
[Music]
you